love that's my approach when it comes to
the oc guys because whenever we have the
opportunity to actually compete globally
i want everyone to have worked their ass
off when that
rules i want you to know there's another
word for that it's called abuse okay we
don't want to we need to make sure
[Laughter]
versus yagami this is winner's finals
first of three now
so let's see how this is gonna play out
we're gonna get massive leads we're
gonna get attrition
oh back turn no good
i like that using these four four moves
to make sure you catch some of the
tracking right there uh especially
versus elisa that's gonna be a thing
oh yeah
yo
you guys are spending your money to vote
your channel points to vote but let me
know in the chat who you got winning
this is it extra men or is it gonna be
yagami let me know in the chat
no you're keeping him in check wow
turning around over the cross-up no
bueno
okay with him but stay in aop which is
just as bad as like not like doing
anything just avoid it
okay orbital side step oh boy
so tricky so tricky
okay
holy crap
oh big mids
yagami really paying attention to the
fact that extra man in this xiaoyu wants
to sidestep a lot and you can see it and
just puts herself really
well gets the counter hit and the combo
though
oh it drops the comeback gets the pickup
god
jesus christ
like they're drawing freaking figure
eights around each other man the amount
of guys on both sides is insane
there's been so much variety in these
matches we've had matches that were
based solely around pokes and now the
combos are coming out and gets to throw
three round straight extreme
extra minutes
right here
i'm gonna i'm gonna have a mint for that
because that was pretty extra mint dude
i have that
man no onions needed it's just so fresh
that i needed my breath to be minty when
i talked about it okay
petrol
a shrek free zone here okay no onions
[Music]
this is what you do i'm gonna tell you
what you do next time you commentate the
match you just shake you just shake it
in the background you just what's that
noise what noise are you talking about
oh that's just my
extra are you just hitting with that
like it's running behind like it's
galloping behind you
what's that noise is it christmas time
now baby that's extra min
extra man let's go that's right he needs
to get a sponsorship he needs to get
sponsored by like something like mint
company
yo you helping him out right now you
better tell him to include you on the
deal okay i was here for that oh yeah fi
find his fate ten percent there you go
man you are a businessman talking smack
to the fellow region as well as making
sure they breath don't stink you're a
stand-up guy here we go yeah man hey
[Music]
someone's gonna be there growing up here
there we go
[Laughter]
wow
don't break on the oneplus 2 oh my god
once again i want to see how these side
steps are going to help you got me out
because you got me that's one of the
things that you got me really changed up
was tracking extra man with the side
step tries to use the blue stuff down
jab to stop the pressure side step on
the running three that was definitely
going to be an aop transition but great
sidestep for elisa and that's one of the
things you got to look for man just like
she's using those tracking moves just
like you see right there you got to use
tracking moves to stop her from
sidestepping it's too good
wow god is okay full combo
oh i don't know if there's a next level
tech right there
okay he's trying to pursue even though
he's at low health he's really getting
in there
i don't get that orbital connects but no
good i caught little low crutch i guess
damn okay so yagami's on this track to
like catch up real quick right now
oh it's coming up
all right nice and slow
oh okay that's pretty raw one okay i
don't know
reverse get it off for me
oh
step on that damn that was quick oh no
back roll right there gives you a free
follow up you see that
[Music]
that was a damn quick round there's
gonna be two actually i think that's
gonna be one oh one up now one one now
you guys uh ties it up now one one
versus extra man
damn so this is gonna be back and forth
i have a feeling it's gonna be back and
forth
now the the choice of infinite stage
worked out for him
you know having the alyssa to be able to
move freely around
they just did a job so huh
i see what yaga means um with extra
minutes might go jungle might go outpost
we'll see we'll see
ah the jungle outpost we might see a
return of huh
but yeah the ling is uh i can tell you
right now the link is moving uh really
making sure that elisa does not have an
easy time like knowing where to attack a
lot of like uh the running threes really
starting to kind of backfire versus
elisa because she could just walk around
it in a lot of instances so you really
yeah yeah yeah
you got to be tight with the strings
this time around
just like you said man jungle outpost
too that's where we're going uh we've
seen this before uh with the ling so a
lot of chances to break the balcony uh i
feel like the transitional issues uh
instances like the balcony break uh the
bottom wall break as well are all really
good answers for lane but of course
elisa can take advantage of him too but
i feel like movement wise yeah ling is
really good at positioning herself to
break those walls in some instances is
even better than at least
oh wow right underneath that
oh there we go
good response and look at this as you
see the exactly what i was talking about
that is just a little thing sidewalks
people damage oh my gosh
yep double low that's
rough two ah
damn you got me in fast forward right
now
look at these sidewalks and look at what
it's doing for yagami's outfits
playing back pretty far right now you're
coming with the people we're punished
i tried to step out of that no good yeah
oh nice oh my god get the the
whole string oh my god
round three oh yagami seems to found it
seems like he's found the secret strat
to take out extra mint right now
there's a standing four
no we punish
mommy trying to use the sprinkler good
punch
yep
again oh my gosh yeah that's doo doo
brown that's that's the big double
damn
that's wild i'm like somebody's trying
to get the grand finals somebody's
trying to get the grand finals
uh one of these guys that's gonna be
guaranteed nothing less than second
place uh guaranteed to get the
underlying share right hundred twenty
one we need to get the lion's share and
uh possibly get the lead in the region
when it comes to points but uh
man
excrement not looking too good right now
i can tell you that
yeah that's not not i don't know how he
just lost that momentum so drastically
with just like what minor changes
nothing really like what do you think
like a shower you would have to do to
get through at this point
like
he's got all the tools really you know
it's not like anything
out of
it seems like they're they're playing
like this this game where it's like all
right i'm going to get in the range
who's going to whip first and then the
sidestep games
more more it becomes more of a thing
right so it's all about it seems like
who's making who's sidestep first and on
top of that the fact that like ling is
really trying to press our offense you
see her offense you see a lot of running
threes to get in a lot of those down
back twos and some instances and now you
see
playing back a little further because
she doesn't want to deal with it and
it's actually working out the whiff
punishers are actually working out in
her favor because she's playing back at
this range so i feel like ling needs to
go in a little bit more ling has the the
movement she has the offense to where
you can make someone slow down but you
just gotta believe in the offense go a
little more crazy if i do say so
look at that lateral movement from yoga
i mean next level
the wall splashes what
this is the situation that we can like
excel in right here
oh the minor punish
this is back to the wall wow that was so
smart didn't press anything big it's the
rage drive wait a minute the blue stuff
and just steal back turn lows goes for
the normal throw we saw it worth one
round not gonna work this time spins the
blue are those for the slide seventeen
seconds goes for the fake out no brain
anyway
you know that one i know
bro you can't say you don't care he gave
you an extra 5 hp to make it tense for
everybody
oh yeah
it really does make a difference in many
many situations it's kind of crazy
bro extra man was literally just
fighting back turn because he knew
yagami was looking for the low goes for
the oneplus 2 not gonna work
small jabs
oh
okay this could be extremely chance to
equal out
nice block
[Music]
oh nice
just got out of it
yeah jabs actually working out there
trying to get the magic oh the mids
beautifully done there you go extra um
extra mint
ah
we're gonna
it's coming up it's coming out oh let's
see
you know what time it is
i can smell your breath right now you
might need
an extra me
it's like some weird premise where like
you feel a breath behind you but then
you start to smell it and it smells very
real good jesus the situation's real bad
something's going on
that's right it's creeping up
not going quietly into the night still
fighting to get to grand finals on the
winner's side i don't blame you because
i'm telling you right now you want that
extra set on your side especially if
you've made it to grand finals
oh yeah yeah it's huge because the thing
is that once you're going to lose the
side then you go into the big gauntlet
because you have to go losers final
grand final reset do it again and then
it's like it's a big stamina run so if
you can just sit pretty in grand final
and just like watch them
bash each other while you just you know
relax in that time you want that
advantage and you get to see what their
behaviors are and how they're acting to
get more information
so yeah infinite stage okay okay this is
good for both of them really but i think
alyssa might have the edge on this i'm
not sure let's see
it did work for him last time
yeah like the movement is in there it is
nice
once again going to the tracking moves
oh oh this is not looking good guess the
following this is flip city right now
oh my god
god like
watch out he's gonna oh he just wanted
to dash away with something okay
almost worked yeah
okay extra man starting strong this
round very aggressive fight
and just abusing the back turn and this
is the offense that i was talking about
you can see extreme gives a lot of
opportunities to go in the aop uh go in
the back turn and your gummy is freezing
a lot of times but i don't think it's
gonna keep working get the combo here
cross up no
goes for the whole hopping throw
oh
just when you thought the garlic was
gonna be too powerful extra mint dude
i don't know with greek food the garlic
is a bit too powerful i don't know
i know oh trust me i know
good job
damn this could be like a reverse voodoo
brown i think from what i can tell
it's like six rounds of paul reverse
oh my god okay he's got a lot of damage
in the pocket
don't get hit again no blocks
man
yo yagami trying to bring it back trade
goes for the down four the lows are
starting to add up big track and move
catches extreme
jab to keep her honest goes back to the
lows tries to sidestep again expands the
blue stuff early you got me in a bad
spot gets the launch though
one more could do it shoeshine
watch for the back turn
oh my god
i could smell that the stone trying to
round close to the load and he got low
powered for it which is devastating
don't smell it the whole room smell that
i like i see what you did there i see
what you did there final final round in
the words of nyk the luigi's are doubled
and you got the launch your gummy drops
the combo reset with the shoe shine
hopping through not gonna work
going back to the lows back to the lows
finishes the string
going for the mid goals for the wall
gets the launches this it goes for a
reason
the scrambles
the scrambles